en este vídeo veremos dos maneras de
reducir al kilos
la primera es una reacción que ya hemos
visto antes esta es la reacción de otro
acción
y la vimos antes cuando hidrogenados al
que nos para formar alcanos aquí vamos a
hidrógeno un al 'chino' para formar un
al que no y para hacer una reacción de
hidrogenación necesitamos algo de gas
hidrógeno algo de h2 justo aquí y luego
un catalizador metálico utilizaremos
paladio inflar el cual es un tipo
especial de catalizador catalizar a la
reducción del al 'chino' en la izquierda
al al que no en la derecha sin embargo
la reducción del al que no al alca no de
aquí abajo es lenta tan tan lenta que
podemos detenerla si nuestra meta es
solo hacer un al que no por lo que esta
reacción forma un al que no sis y fue
una adicción sin de nuestros hidrógenos
obtendremos los dos hidrógenos
añadiéndose en el mismo lado y esto
tiene que ver con el mecanismo de una
reacción de hidrogenación puedes revisar
el vídeo anterior de hidrogenación de al
que nos para ver más detalles el paladio
link lar un catalizador envenenado
reducirá un al 'chino' aún al que no
producirá un al que nos is bien así es
como se hace un al que nos veamos cómo
hacer un al que no trans como reducimos
un al 'chino' para hacer un al que no
trans
aquí está nuestro alquilo
tenemos nuestro triple enlace así y
añadiremos sodio metálico y también
agregaremos amoniaco líquido así
así que formaremos un al que no trans
pondré esta vez mis dos hidrógenos
estarán en lados opuestos uno del otro
está en la formación de un al que no
trans
así
y hace esto con una adición anti
de hidrógeno es cierto se añaden en
lados opuestos de esta manera veamos el
mecanismo para formar un al que no trans
empiezo con mi al 'chino'
y continuaré poniendo mis carbonos ahí y
poniendo un grupo r en el lado izquierdo
y haré es de un grupo r prima para
distinguirlo del grupo r de ahí
empezamos con sodio
el cual sabemos que al estar en el grupo
uno tiene un electrón de valencia así
y en el primer paso del mecanismo este
átomo de sodio donará su electrón de
valencia al alki no cuando estamos
mostrando el movimiento de un electrón
usamos una flecha de media cabeza
mostraré este electrón moviéndose para
acá pero es solo un electrón por lo que
sólo haré una flecha de media cabeza así
y no una flecha de cabeza completa uno
de estos enlaces de aquí entre los
carbonos se romperá y uno de los
electrones se moverá a este carbono así
y uno de los electrones se moverá a este
carbono en la izquierda así que
continuamos dibujando el resultado de
todos esos electrones moviéndose
tenemos un grupo r aquí
y tuvimos un triple enlace pero ahora
solo tenemos un doble enlace entre
nuestros dos carbonos
y luego tenemos que reprima por aquí
el carbono en la derecha tomo un
electrón del sodio y también tomo un
electrón del rompimiento de ese enlace
ahora tiene dos electrones alrededor así
lo que nos da una carga formal de menos
1 en este carbono por lo que es un kart
bañón es una unión el carbono en la
izquierda tomo un electrón del
rompimiento de ese enlace así ese es un
radical es algo de lo que no hemos
hablado antes de hecho hemos formado
algo que es conocido como añón radical
continuamos escribiendo eso este es un
guión
radical
radical porque hay un electrón no ha
apareado ahí y luego también tiene un
kart bañón en la misma molécula así
tenemos estos electrones que están
bastante juntos por lo menos como los
dibujes cierto sabemos que todos los
electrones están cargados negativamente
por lo que todos estos electrones se
repelerán entre sí por lo que esta no es
la forma más estable que esta molécula
puede tener en términos de conformación
estos electrones se repelen
y querrán intentar estar lo más alejados
que puedan uno del otro lo que sucederá
es tenemos nuestros dos carbonos justo
aquí y digamos que estos dos electrones
permanecen aquí en este lado y este
electrón irá al lado opuesto intentarán
llegar lo más lejos posible el uno del
otro y lo mismo pasa con este grupo r
aquí cierto este grupo r intentará estar
lo más lejos posible de este grupo r
prima por lo que esta conformación trans
es la más estable este de aquí es
nuestro carbayón cargado negativamente
en el siguiente paso del mecanismo
recordamos que el amoniaco está presente
continuamos dibujando una molécula de
amoniaco flotando alrededor así aquí
está nuestra molécula de amoniaco y el
carbayón actuará como una base y tomará
un protón de la molécula de amoniaco
este par libre de electrones formará un
nuevo enlace con este protón y estos
electrones se moverán al nitrógeno
continuamos dibujando en los resultados
de esa reacción ha sido base ahora
tenemos nuestros dos carbonos con un
grupo r aquí y r prima justo ahí y ahora
este carbono en la derecha está unido a
un protón
se enlazó a un hidrógeno así y luego aún
tenemos nuestro radical aquí abajo hay
un electrón en ese carbono también bien
el siguiente paso de nuestro mecanismo
bien hay mucho sodio presente aquí hay
un átomo de sodio con un electrón de
valencia y el sodio donará este electrón
a este carbono solo usa una flecha de
media cabeza para mostrar el movimiento
de un electrón si ese átomo de sodio
dona ese electrón de valencia a ese
carbono continuamos dibujando el
resultado de eso tenemos 2 carbonos
doblemente enlazados un grupo r por aquí
un hidrógeno y una r prima
y este carbono tenía un electrón
alrededor acaba de tomar uno más de ese
átomo de sodio está así lo que le dará
una carga formal de menos 1 este carbono
tiene una carga formal de menos 1
continuamos dibujando esa carga formal
de menos 1
es un kart bañón y nuevamente el
amoniaco está flotando alrededor
continuamos dibujando el amoniaco justo
aquí
así nh3 y lo mismo pasará como lo
hicimos antes cierto la carga negativa
tomará un protón
actuará como una base y estos electrones
se moverán al nitrógeno aquí y entonces
protón amos nuestro carbón
y hemos completado nuestro mecanismo
porque ahora tenemos nuestros dos grupos
r
uno frente al otro y añadimos dos
hidrógenos uno frente al otro también
así
formamos un al que no trans bien ese es
el mecanismo para formar un al que no
trans veamos algunos ejemplos empecemos
con este al 'chino' de aquí viene un
carbono con un triple enlace a otro
carbono y pondremos un grupo metilo
en cada lado
así
y hagamos algunas reacciones diferentes
con el mismo sustrato aquí
nuestra primera reacción sólo será una
hidrogenación normal con gas hidrógeno y
usemos platino como nuestro catalizador
este no es un catalizador envenenado es
un catalizador normal lo que pasará es
primero reducirás el alc y no aun al que
no y luego ya que no hay manera de
pararlo se reducirá el al que no alcanzó
a esto reducirá el alc y no hasta un
arcano si regresamos al inicio
recuerda dijimos que un catalizador
envenenado se detendrá en el al que no
pero si no es un catalizador envenenado
sólo hidrógeno hará tal que no alcanzó
aquí abajo así que esta reacción
producirá un arcano continuamos
dibujando el producto
sabemos que hay cuatro carbonos en mis
materiales iniciales habrá
4 carbonos cuando acabe con esto estos 2
carbonos aquí en el centro se
convertirán en c h 2 y luego en cada
lado aún tenemos nuestros c h
esto formará butano como producto bien
esta vez usemos
gas hidrógeno y usemos paladio
lynn marc aquí este es nuestro
catalizador envenenado por lo que
reducirá nuestro al chino al que no y
luego se detendrá y debes pensar qué
tipo de al que no obtendrás obtendrás un
al que gnosis si dibujamos nuestros dos
hidrógenos
agregándose en los mismos lados ahora
tenemos nuestros grupos metilo de esta
manera nuestros grupos metilo así este y
este será nuestro producto un al que
gnosis bien hagamos uno más el mismo
material inicial este de aquí excepto
que esta vez añadiremos sodio y usaremos
amoniaco como nuestro solvente y
recuerda esto reducirá nuestro al
'chino' aún al que no pero formará un al
que no trans como nuestro producto
cuando dibujas tu producto aquí abajo
quieres asegurarte que tus dos
hidrógenos son trans uno del otro así
que se añaden al mecanismo
y luego tus dos grupos metilo
estarán también en lados opuestos así
y pon mucha atención con lo que estás
haciendo reaccionar las cosas es una
reacción de hidrogenación normal es una
reacción de hidrogenación con un
catalizador envenenado cual formaría una
al kénosis o es reducción con sodio y
amoniaco cual te dará un al que no trans